ow
ah hey I'm out of breath now hello
everybody my name is Margo bar I'm out
of breath
welcome to cool dog teaches typing tip
paying tip tip typing press any key
OOP I'm legitimately out of breath that
sorry about type of my name huh you're
cool dog you're cool dog you you you're
cool dog with the Miranda sings style
lipstick you're cool dog and you put it
in your eyes - you're cool dog seemed
pretty cool to me ah I'll just call you
student my name is Maya [ __ ] is
what I was gonna type Oh
you're typing per second will show up
here
do I need to type real words or what is
that going to pay higher oh geez oh geez
okay I don't think I had any effect on
that oh yeah much better you've got
later okay Oh over to your office I
don't know the old God where am I Oh
baby you'll be okay look down at your
computer to start a lesson Wow
if you want to take a typing break you
can go up outside make yourself at home
okay I feel like a squirrel
born into a situation that I was not
prepared for my typing skills I'll get
through it in a second I need to talk to
my peeps out there so if you're lost
meet you ah I guess I'm gonna learn
typing from cool dog I got it oh god
what happened to my hands [ __ ] hell
what it typing can be hard this is an
easy lesson what the hell is a keyboard
this type what's on the screen and try
not to hit extra keys with your paws you
got all to time don't worry
typing isn't so hard and can actually
I'm sorry let me just smack my hands on
the keyboard okay yeah yeah all right
yeah I just do this for the wall oh
happy whoops I mean Kass locks it me
really fun once you whoa doctor you get
good at it the quick brown fox jumped
over the cool dog you've maybe heard
that one before cool story that Fox was
actually my roommate in college Nick
something good movie AK chore I am way
too busy teaching and and planets income
beautiful what to be in movies back to
to the lesson you are do doing good only
oh no you sack of [ __ ] okay so
eventually that'll be correct
finishing low less songs will unlock
harder one
okay good good thing I put the zeros in
there check your score and see how good
you are at the end of every lesson okay
we're done you can stop typing now cool
that's not bad but you still juice oh
yeah I goofed
zero times hell yeah hell yeah hell yeah
home row well if that isn't the scariest
thing I've ever seen in my life
another lesson coming right up this time
we focus on the middle home row of the
keyboard and it's going back to my Mavis
Beacon fifth grade B's try using your
back paws okay
the middle keys on the cow on the
keyboard are called the home go home row
they are easier to tap because they are
so big some example s are afk okay esta
ml and okay words like Batman are whoa
are impossible hi oh my god hey hi this
will be covered in another lesson thanks
for staying to learn about the normal
home row cuter welcome back puppy boards
at this pace you're each yellow bill
belt Piper in noontime good job huzzah
whoa hey all right okay I was pretty
fast he was pretty fast
how about you put those typing skills to
the test and help me look some stuff up
okay cool I feel like I'm gonna hear
that in my nightmares tonight all right
after that last lesson I had some
computer questions to search I'll be go
through my notes okay I don't even know
if I should be reading that when he's
marrying through human paws are cold
they have up to try ruh fingers each and
27 bones hands are good at holding and
and pressing some words that hand hand
in them are handy handwriting handiwork
handle handbag handsome hand ball
fingerprints are all different just like
just like what smells oh yes
good old butt smells hand move movies
and the hand Cool Hand Luke Edward
Scissorhands star wars episode 1 the
andum Menace a hand riddle handsome
Hansel handsome boy handed a handful of
handlebars ah handle each a handy
Chandler chandelier done did little you
who are you now typing I know I know
goodbye for now wait what cool dog
cool dog no believe me I feel like this
game is taking a lot out of me so anyway
I guess I'm all done here we did done
did learn how to type and that was
pretty important for everybody and
everyone saw how many mistakes I make in
my general typing career but either way
I hope you enjoyed that if you want to
learn how to type yourself go down the
description learn now as always I will
see you
in the next video